greetings
my name is timothy snyder i'm the leaven
professor of history at yale university
i am greeting and welcoming you this
evening on behalf of
the the the frankie program which has
enabled me along with my colleague
professor jason stanley to teach a
seminar this semester on
mass incarceration in the soviet union
and the united states
this is the last of these lectures that
i'll be introducing so i want to make a
special point of thanking richard and
barbara frankie for their support of the
humanities in particular at yale this is
much appreciated in general in
particular i've been very glad to be
able to teach this class
so this class this seminar on mass
incarceration in ussr in the u.s
is getting towards its middle point at
this point
our students have have spent a couple of
weeks reading about the origins of the
gulag and the functioning of the gulag
this week um you who are not our
students are joining us as we move on to
the subject of the experience of the
gulag
one of the one of the most important
chroniclers of the soviet camps was a
polish artist whose name was joseph
chopsky
yusef chopsky is what i should say was
until a few years ago someone who was
idolized by i would say the best part of
the polish intelligencia
thanks to our speaker this evening eric
carpolis yusef chopsky has moved from
being someone who is known to a few as
an outstanding painter and chronicler of
the 20th century to to become a figure
who can be now and is becoming now
much more widely known
i'm a historian and i've always
understood yusuf chopsky in terms of his
experiences
but uh but eric carpolis who is himself
an artist and a translator as well as a
writer
someone who who found
chopsky by way of proust which is an
extraordinary connection when chopski
was in a soviet camp he was allowed to
give french lessons and he did so in the
form of recapitulating remembrance of
things passed by by proust which is for
me one of the most extraordinary
civilizational achievements imaginable
and and deep and profound that all in
all in all kinds of ways but eric
carpolis came came to chopski from a
different direction he came to chopski
by way of proust and by way of art and
discovered or rediscovered him as a
painter and then has contributed in fact
essentially all by himself has created a
revival of yusuf chopsky in the west in
the english language by retranslating
the the lecture notes that chopski gave
about proust in the soviet camp by
compiling the art into an
extraordinarily beautiful volume which
i'm going to bring to class tomorrow and
by writing
an accessible and even for me who
thought we thought he knew the life
pretty well a striking and original and
persuasive biography of of chopski
called called almost nothing which i'm
going to do my duty and and hold up now
people speak of dog-eared copies as
though it's a cliche but this you can
see that this is actually a dog-eared
copy so at this point in the class we're
very welcome very very happy to be able
to welcome
eric carpolis um we are we are trying to
we're trying to consider what it would
be like to experience and think about
and see the gulag and you just chopski
is there could be no better figure than
uzub chopsky for that but more than that
um
the the the class needs to reach a point
where we understand that the people who
experience the gulag are experiencing it
thoughtfully by way of other things they
bring to it that their lives are not
just determined by this experience of
incarceration yusuf chopski is an
example of someone for whom
incarceration was very important for
himself but i perhaps more so for for
his friends and his his comrades and his
colleagues who he later tried to
remember but he was above all an artist
who lived an almost century-long life so
i'm very pleased at this point in the
class we're going to be able to
seriously introduce art as part of the
history or part of the approach to mass
incarceration this is a theme and an
approach alongside philosophy
and and history which i hope will be
able to keep going so there's no one
better to do this for us than ericopolis
eric i'm very glad that you were able to
join us um i welcome you on behalf of
all the people whom who can see you but
whom you can't see and i'm very much
looking forward to your lecture and to
your presentation thank you
it's certainly an honor uh to
see a copy of my book read by you with
those dog-eared pages it makes a great
impression upon me
um i will say that right now i need to
see how
um so joseph chopsky facing the void
i have
chosen the title
uh
as a way of expressing
uh the context of this class and
and the way in which chopski can
interact
with the subject at large
facing the void is is in one way
of looking at um
the world
the 20th century which chopsky lived
through
he lived into his 97th year
and also a way of the internal
life of chopski in which he always
felt the need to
to create as a way of filling the void
as a way of making comment on the world
around him czech was an enormously
large character he
will fit very tightly be shoehorned into
this short lecture of mine which could
actually warrant an entire semester of
study so uh without a lot of further ado
i'm just going to jump in i've been
asked by professor snyder to to put him
in a context
of of the world in which the the class
uh takes place and also to speak about
him as an artist
which i feel more comfortable in but i
will run you through all of this
so
we're going to begin
with um
this is the world in which chopski was
born
in 1896
it's a map of central and eastern europe
and russia and it rightly suggests the
very specific and firm
uh international imperial borders but it
fails to note that
beyond these borders
um
cultural
and
societal norms were transgressed that
this was not something that stopped at a
border that that these
uh these societies all
interacted with each other
chapsey's family
was just outside of minsk where their
lands were
and
this is in what today is known as
belarus
the home in which chapski grew up his
childhood home uh here he is with his
parents on the left and his
five sisters and one brother
uh
his mother was an austrian countess and
his father was a polish count
a polish count who grew up speaking
french and german and russian but who
only learned polish
at university
this was a world peopled by highly
cosmopolitan individuals citizens of the
world rather than people defined by a
single national identity
chebsky had russian baltic czech and
german cousins
he was born in prague in 1896 in one of
his mother's family's palaces it was a
great life of privilege
it was his mother the austrian countess
however who decided that her children
should be raised as what she liked to
call her little poles
when he turned seven when he turned 13
chaps and his younger brother were
shipped off to st petersburg to improve
their russian with the expectation that
their time would come to run the family
estate
and to prepare for the balcony
five years later in 1914 the first world
war was systematically destroying the
old life of europe slaughtering a
generation of young men
chapski still in petersburg
and deeply immersed in telstra and
spiritualism
was
he was very young and he was very
vulnerable
and
tolstoy meant a great deal to him
and he wrestled with his feelings about
religion about god um
but to keep them from being sent to the
front as war fodder
chopski's father enrolled his two boys
in the elite military training school
the court of polish in saint petersburg
this self-portrait which was drawn at
the time was the first
of a long line of self-portraits
chelsea presented himself as a military
cadet and a young man of the world
he was still in petersburg when both the
february and october revolutions
erupted in 1917 and he was deeply marked
by the experience
he returned to warsaw in 1918
and decided to pursue a course of study
and painting rather than to continue on
with his training as a pianist
in february of 1919
tensions exploded between the newly
minted second republic of poland and
soviet russia not yet the soviet union
abandoning his course of study at the
fine arts academy warsaw chopski
volunteered immediately from military
service
his courage in combat earned him the
polish order of the virtuti military the
country's highest military decoration
he received this medal at the same time
as a french officer who would become a
friend of his
charle de gaulle who had been sent to
poland as an observer
the friendship survived over the decades
to come
back from the front he enrolled at the
academy of fine arts in krakow a city
where he knew no one
chopski would recall i entered the world
of my new friends where an intellectual
atmosphere marked by a carefree
assurance a winning optimism an
essential joie de vivre was totally
alien to me
chapski as you can see in this picture
grew to enormous heights he was six feet
six inches
tall everyone however
knew him as usual which is a an
affectionate diminutive of the name
yusuf
um it's one of those contradictions that
chopsy's life is full of
but largely it's the sense of the scale
of him that's so impressive always
as a painting student
he was caught between the historical
religious
requirements of the traditional polish
painting
and at the same time
what was going on in warsaw was the
fashionable
leaning towards post cubic
cubist ideological
movements like futurism and formism
neither of these polls was particularly
appealing to him as a painter as a
painting student
and he
and a group of like-minded students
bonded together
they raised money hoping they could
finance a trip to spend six weeks in
paris where all the action was in
painting they felt they were in a
backwater they recognized that and hoped
to move on they gave a ball to raise
money they did all sorts of fundraising
things and they raised enough money
to spend six weeks in paris
they succeeded and departed for paris
but instead of
staying six weeks they stayed seven
years
they became known as the committee of
paris
and ever after their return to poland
they were known as the cappists
chopski's seven years in paris were
enormously important
they were marked by his immersion in the
painting of bernard matisse
the group's attending professor the
painter joseph makievich who's shown in
the self-portrait on the bottom left of
the screen was an old friend of bow nile
the two of them used to go to the south
together every summer and paint side by
side
it was a time in which he
shared uh
with his sister his sister maria who
became enormously important to him and
the two of them were together for most
of their lives
their long lives she was also as tall as
he she was very striking she became a
historian
eventually the polish painters had the
excitement of their own first exhibition
which gave them praise from such
recognized figures as duffy ruelt and
even bernard himself
chapski was able to sell his first
paintings including one to gertrude
stein
on the right you see the image of what's
called the empastahui
which is that building
was where the painters
communally met every day to work in
studio space
there were many influences on chapski at
the time he had come to paris to see the
real painting going on
and in the falling groups of slides i've
shown on the left
a known painter and chopsky's work that
somehow
shows the influence and the
effect of coming in contact with this
kind of painting
here cezanne
the fellow on the right the portrait is
of a man named shil aransan
who was a um
an art critic that chopsky knew
here is matisse
on the left
and on the right we see chopski's
closest attempt at fovism this is a way
in which you see the influence of
technique of color of form
learning from the masters
souteen
chopsky on the right
chopski on the left in this case
you can see him
painting with a certain crude
stroke
and yet with a great amount of animation
of vitality and of
an interest in color
bernard was a terrific influence on
chopsky
these works on
paper with pencil and watercolor and
colored pencil but primarily in the
intensity of the color in his canvases
in 1930 after having mounted the group
exhibition of the gallery's act
chapski headed to spain for six weeks in
the vast halls of the prado he had what
he called the shock of my life
standing before the huge array of works
by goya he was overwhelmed his masterful
portraits
of great ladies dignitaries cardinals
and kings are patient so smoothly to the
degree that you don't feel the brush
they're classical and composition and
miraculous in the control of every
detail chaps he wrote and the in the
materiality of the object and the
consideration given to local colors in
the gradation
of values
next to these portraits
in another room
hung badly
were paintings by goya so extremely
different that it was difficult to
believe they were painted by the same
person
war scenes wild scenes with witches so
frenzied we see all the brush strokes
color contrast is violent they rival
sateen
and the disdain for local color and the
object's materiality
such that the canvases sometimes give
the impression of almost abstract color
relations
speaking of myself chapski went on i was
long tormented by a duality of approach
analytic on the one hand rational
growing from the dutch tradition
and on the other hand the mad the
unpredictable the true leap into the
abyss
in this i saw a lack of integrated
personality in myself
a kind of psychic dividedness that i
tried to overcome artificially without
success
but then i noticed the same phenomena in
a painter whose stature was not only
equal to that of matisse but who was one
of the very greatest
i speak about goya
by 1931
excuse me
by 1931 the group of polish pantries had
returned to poland
chopsky set up a studio in warsaw and
entered directly into the flow of the
artistic scene there he began to write
about painting as well and to exhibit
his work on a daily basis on a yearly
basis
we find in his work from these years the
seed of the french style transplanted
into polish soil
taking root
bearing fruit
yet these paintings tend to conform to a
range of stylistic options that feel
imposed from without
tried on like various guises rather than
emanating from somewhere within
strengthened by goya's example chapski
is nevertheless still finding his way
learning as he
goes these paintings were done
at a time
when
the bloomsbury group painters were
actually very closely
experimenting in the same way with
changing old painting styles here's
chapski
coming down the hallway
you can see that yellow bar about a
third of the way up
from the bottom of the canvas across the
canvas which is not quite opaque in
which you can see the turn of the carpet
coming towards you down the hall chebsky
is still learning his medium here
in the mid-1930s
met a young writer named ludwig herring
in their own tortured way they overcame
their constraining religious scruples
and allowed themselves to fall in love
to set up home as far as was possible
and so repressive an environment
knowledge of this unconventional setup
of what was perceived as their flaunting
of societal norms
is what has continued to this day to
mute the response of the community in
poland to chopski's achievements and his
indisputable historical significance
the two men had several heartening
emotional nurturing years together
and remained in close spiritual contact
until the death of heron who ill with
cancer committed suicide in 1984.
this is one of chapski's paintings
just before war broke out 1937
this is the promenade at support
on the baltic sea
just outside of what was then known as
danzig
you can see the nazi flags
along the promenade
on september 1st
poland was invaded
by germany in the air on the ground the
sea
on september 2nd the next day chapski
went to join his cavalry regiment as a
reserve officer
aged 43.
on the 27th of september he and his
regiment were surrounded by germans
outside of
surprisingly they were handed over to
the russian forces who had invaded
poland from the east on the 16th
he spent six months at starbucks in
ukraine as a prisoner of war in a camp
with at first 11 000 fellow prisoners
under severe conditions of crowding and
lack of food
in the first months
in june 1940 he was finally transferred
with
very few other
of his
prisoner colleagues
to a camp at griez soviets
north of moscow
here's a self-portrait he made in the
camp at grazovia it's this is the
beginning of our understanding of
chopsky uh and his relationship to
drawing and to his journals
he
kept a journal throughout the war which
became a source of much of his writing
and of his memory of the experience
um
in the book uh by
julius
margolien that you're also reading for
this class
he says that
no one in the camps no one retains his
original form
observation is difficult because the
observer himself is deformed
this was a test that chopsky had set
himself
an attempt not to become deformed to
remain true to himself
and to help his fellow prisoners
also
keep focused and keep true to themselves
they were constantly bombarded by soviet
propaganda over loudspeakers in the camp
but they struggle to to keep trigger
themselves
chopski's war was was not the same
certainly as margolin's there were
different
territories and different
uh demands upon each of them but there
was something about
chopski's resistance to the hammering of
soviet propaganda that was very
inspiring
so
russia in russia
paper was enormously valuable it was not
of good quality but it was very rare and
hard to come by he did whatever he could
to get notebooks and he filled them
this is a drawing of one of his
friends in the camp a man named adam
shinsky this is a drawing
on both sides of one piece of paper i'm
showing both sides of it he filled every
page he could
and got pencils as he could and
materials as he could but painting
was out of the question really
drawing and use of watercolors was what
he had at hand and he made the best of
it
more drawings of prison companions
he wrote that the sense of being totally
unsure if we would ever see anything
again in our lives apart from barbed
wire fences and this alien hostile world
the sense of being buried alive was
cruel
it seemed very unlikely that we would
ever get beyond the wire
unless to get a bullet in the back of
the head
uh professor snyder made reference to
the french lessons that chomsky was able
to give this is his french notebook for
those uh lectures that he gave
he decided to
like shaharazad every night
tell a little bit of the portion of
proust's great novel
in search of lost time
um he took extensive notes which are in
themselves quite beautiful drawings if
you know proust you can see a little bit
on the left some of the names of the
characters
but the sketch itself the diagram in
which he
unfolds chopsky like a cosmology
is made in both
polish and french and german
in the russian
different pages
carrying different diagrams
this was
an understanding for chopsky
of the
attempt to remember
what he had read he
read proust in the 20s when he was in
paris as each of the volumes came out
he was in a soviet camp where he had no
books no access to the material so in
order to speak about proust he had to
remember proust and this is in a way a
kind of manifestation of the very
christian
enterprise the attempt to recall the
past and to make use of it in the
present
he wrote
that intellectual effort when conducted
without books or notes gives an entirely
different sensation than when carried
out under normal conditions
one's involuntary memory acts much more
forcefully the memory of which proof
speaks and which he considered to be the
sole source of literary creation
after a certain amount of time things
surface in our consciousnesses
details we have the slightest idea were
even stored anywhere in our brain
what is more these memories that arise
from our subconscious are more deeply
rooted more intimately bound up with
another
more personal
chebsky helped his fellow prisoners
to
again
nurture themselves their interior lives
and to
use this experience of sharing produced
as a way of
hardening them against
the realities outside and nurturing
their inner lives
on june 22nd
1941
everything was up ended to this day
chapski wrote i can still hear ringing
in my ears a scruffy colonel bending his
upper body from the window shouting
hitler attacked russia
a new phase of the war began
stalin provisionally agreed to free all
polish prisoners and deportees in order
to form an independent polish army
within the red army to fight their
former ally now their common enemy
general vladislav anders confined in
moscow's notorious lubyanka prison where
he had been tortured and spent 27 months
in solitary
had been chosen to command the new
polish order
he had no shoes he walked slowly from
wounds inflicted by beatings and he wore
a prison uniform
on that day he was introduced to two of
russia's most powerful pull-up bureau
members merkulov and beria
who escorted him to a limousine where he
was whisked to meetings about the
formation of a new polish division of
the red army
soldier prisoners
began to gather from all the vast
corners of the gulag to join the new
polish division
but
most of the officers
never
reappeared
chopski was assigned to interrogate the
new arrivals to investigate what had
become their of their officers but
thousands of thousands of rank and file
soldiers passed by his desk and produced
not one link to the whereabouts of a
single officer
anders then ordered chapski to find them
arming him with letters of introduction
from the commander of the polish army
for months he traveled
about across the soviet union in search
of news of these men
but over and over again he ran straight
into a wall of silence
in the meantime stalin was determined to
send these new polish recruits to the
front
but the men poorly fed inadequately
armed and unable to train for combat
having just been released from a year
and a half of deprivation and squalor
indus resisted stalin's pressure and
insisted the men be suitably recovered
and trained for the current conditions
of war
by order of indus chapski was named
chief officer of information and
propaganda for the polish army and he
had the considerable distinction of
being in daily contact with founders is
commander-in-chief
when it became clear that a standoff
had happened in the spring of 1942
stalin agreed to let the polish troops
evacuate to iran where they would be fed
by british rations
and then move on to iraq
this map shows the routes taken by the
anders army and by chopski from his
capture
in september 1939
over the course of the next five and a
half years
this is an enormous undertaking to move
all of these men
throughout the war chopski continued to
keep his journal making elaborate notes
drawing people and scenes he witnessed
on the left is an album from these years
in the middle east
means borderlands
uzbekistan turkmenistan kazakhstan all
the places
that the polish army had been stationed
before its exodus
on the right
his journal once they arrived in egypt
one night in tashkent he was invited to
a literary gathering where he
encountered the russian poet matava
whose poems chopski knew well
at this time her poetry
was revered by many but officially
reviled considered decades in bourgeois
by the reigning authorities on aesthetic
taste
her work was banned by the regime
and she could no longer publish
chopski was surprised to find her
widow of a poet murdered by the state
sitting quietly if aloof in a soviet
office's private home
chebsky was asked to read some polish
poetry which he then translated into
russian
you saw matava listening intently tears
in her eyes
he gently persuaded her to share some of
her poems
chomsky learned
that stalin himself admired some of
akmatova's work and it was he personally
who ensured her safety
in the presence of this elegant strong
woman
with her sharp alert mind chopsky found
evidence of nearly schizophrenic
atmosphere
imposed on the closed society of russian
artists
chopski was the first non-russian
akmatova had met in over 20 years
that night they walked together late at
night after dinner and stayed up until
dawn speaking
years later chopsky learned that she had
written a poem about that night about
the impact of his presence
upon her
they met once more in 1965
as she was returning from receiving a
doctorate at oxford on her way back to
russia
she had ditched her followers
her uh soviet
escort and gone directly to paris and
saw him
was in iraq on april 13th 1943
when radio berlin broadcast the news
of the discovery of mass graves in a
forest in western russia
these
were some of the men
i'm sorry
i'm still
bringing chopski through the middle east
here
drawing as he goes
documenting his trip
aspects of travel aspect of daily life
and an army full of men
at repose
playing soccer or bathing
showering
these are some of the men chapstick had
been devoted to finding
among them
many close friends
the broadcast from radio berlin had
announced the graves
this is what was dug up
these were scenes of
outside of cutting in the forest
of the bodies of
polish officers who were still in their
great coats
shot in the back of the head
forever after for the next 50 years
chabska would make it his duty to remind
the world of the fate of 22 thousand of
these polish officers and civilians
the polish army pushed on
out of the middle east to jerusalem and
tel aviv eventually to cairo and port
saeed where they boarded ships for the
italian peninsula
chapski was at anders side during the
planning for the assault on germans who
had dug in for months at the montessori
at the monastery atlanta casino
ceaselessly bombed by the allies in
hopes of dislodging them and opening the
road to rome
you can see in the picture on the bottom
the ghostly
remains of the monastery which had once
been such a beautiful
retreat
the poles in their first foray at
soldiering since leading the soviet
union fought valiantly and at a great
loss of life but succeeded in uprooting
the germans on the morning of may 18th
the monastery was theirs
chebsky had few illusions about the
allies for whom the big news that season
was the invasion of normandy in the
liberation of paris
from the polls still traumatized by the
discovery of the katim massacre
the most important event of the late
spring of 1944
was the warsaw uprising
chopski's sister maria had remained in
warsaw through the methodical
destruction of most of the city by nazi
troops
as chopski feared all of his work that
he had stored away before leaving to
join his regiment in september 1939 his
paintings his writings his diaries was
destroyed
along with so much else
his sense of unease about the allies
proved well justified
in february 1945 at the altar conference
stalin solidified his iron grip on
poland
still in rome with the ander's army
chopsky published a memoir of his prison
experience
memoir memories of starabilsk
drawn from his daily journal attended to
throughout his years as a soldier
a friend who had been a prisoner in the
labor camp in siberia at the same time
described chopski's account of life as a
prisoner as
lived by a pole
meditated on by a european
written by a painter
the book was printed and circulated just
as the war ended and was largely ignored
or met with hostility by both soviets
and allies
as the
army of anders broke up in rome in
1945
chopski and a group of his like-minded
friends
determined that they would create
a institute called the polish literary
institute
they decided to base it in paris
they put their funds together and came
up with a home not this one this is the
second home but um outside of paris in a
quiet suburb called maison lafite and
this house which is
almost iconic in russian cultural
history uh still stands today is still
the home of the polish literary
institute
chopski took up residence in this upper
floor in this room with the open window
at the back of the house
it was to be his
library his salon
and his painting studio for the next 50
years all of the work we see from here
on and will have come out from this
little room
men like
yeshi guilders who's shown here with
chopsky
ziggman and zasha hertz
gustav helling
these and others after months and months
of conversations as soldiers in the
anders army created the institute once
the army was disbanded
they invested no faith in the redemptive
powers of the west
they fully understood the corrosive
shadow cast at galta
chapski and guidrich and a handful of
other dedicated souls created from
nothing the magazine cultura one of the
most influential and widely read
journals of the 20th century cultura had
an astonishing run of 637 issues
spanning a 53-year window of time
looking back cultura was synonymous with
poland itself
acting in loco parentis for the polish
institutions denied the right to exist
on the ground in poland itself
the first issue
shown on the left here included works by
lorca paul vareli
arthur kessler
chapski debuted with a tribute to
bernard who had recently died
chomsky was torn between his
cosmopolitan self and the polish role of
events the war foisted on him
he only reluctantly embraced a
nationalism that ran counter to his
instinctual bohemianism
but he he overcame that resistance
and in his created response to it he
wrote the memoir called inhuman land
some of you you've read some of these
pages for this class
chotsky said that i was not free to
write what i wanted
but i needed to write what i must
his difficulties in getting in human
land published reflect the state
of the french left's tenacious romance
with stalinism
failing to find a publisher chapski's
book was excerpted in the second and
third issues of kutura
only two years later in 1949 his old
friend daniel alive finally found a
publisher willing to print the entire
book if someone else paid for the cost
of publication
despite encouragement from martha
kessler and george orwell
no english publisher would touch it
david rousseau was a left-wing french
journalist and authority on
nazi concentration camps a survivor of
buchenwald and noon gum
his expose of those worlds
called the truth about the camps had
been well received
yet a review of rousseau's book by art
critic and editor pierre dix
claimed that he was slandering the
soviet union and was making false claims
against it
who
rousseau
sued for libel
at the trial
chopski appeared as a witness answering
questions about his years in starabilsk
the lawyers for dixte tried to undermine
his credibility as a witness
going further and holding forth about
the murders of his fellow poles of
cutting
chopski stunned the courtroom
enraging the defense team and unleashing
an uproar
the george was forced to call a recess
chopski's sphere of influence was
considerable as he settled into maison
lafite and a life in paris he had access
to many key players in the shaping of
post-war europe political religious
cultural figures whose doors were open
to him and who were largely sympathetic
to the fates of the poles in exile
the sketch chopski did of de gaulle
malhot
had met when he was in paris in the 20s
and he continued their relationships
camus he met
and became a
colleague in publishing
camus relied on chopsky for translations
of his books in polish and they had a
a very close and personal relationship
in 1946 as he began to settle into paris
life
chopski turned 50
just as he was about to settle into a
routine
painting getting a discipline back uh
guilderish
imposed upon him to go abroad and to
raise money for culture
so he
once again put aside his brushes
and traveled to south america to north
america to
to raise money for the magazine visiting
both large cities and small polish
communities
with him all the time was his
sketchbook he documented all of his
trips quite thoroughly
finally
in the early 1950s
chopsky begins to paint and to paint in
earnest shifting his priorities to the
studio upstairs at the back of the house
in these on lafitte
here is characteristic a scene that
caught chopski's eye and imagination
what is it that makes it worthy of being
a painting
chapski believed that the truth of
everyday life and the truth of art were
interchangeable
unlike the generations of polish
religious and historical painters who
constructed heightened costume dramas he
preferred to find humbler subjects close
at hand
for chapski people waiting for a train
were capable of revealing as much about
the metaphysics of being
as any annunciation or resurrection
he did not go out in search of subjects
they appeared to him as he went about
living his life
always alert to the possible combination
of elements that might cohere into a
memorable image in his mind's eye
the scientists for whom this metro stop
was named louis pasteur
once proclaimed about research
in the field of observation chance
favors the prepared mind
chopski had such a mind
chopski declared that the precision of
the eye not the precision of the hand is
the first and most important task
this is a variation on the
saying of turner
paint what you see not what you know
the result was often a canvas that in
chapstick's own words could set one's
teeth on edge with a subject that could
as often as not be revolting
he took his strength from goya
he noted that a great many criticized me
for painting the filthy steps of the gar
san lazaro in paris
he considered woman in front of a train
to be
his masterpiece
although
that changed from time to time
old women had a particular fascination
for him and he admired their tactics of
survival here the woman is a cipher she
clearly has had her share of woe
this picture belongs to the genre of
vanitas paintings in which a painter
addresses
the transcency of life the certainty of
death and the folly of pleasurable
pursuits
that hat that handbag through shoes
the fire in the painting is banked low
an orange glow at the bottom of the
train
evoking a sense of embers burning
steadily inside of her
subdued
well beyond the flames of youth
it's something of a tribute to chopski's
iconoclasm
to try to call up another painter who
draws from both goya and matisse in the
same painting
here you can see these shoes that
matisse has buckled on the left
echoed on the right so cheopski had
within this one canvas
a combination of influences and yet
his own inimitable style
by the late 50s he was exhibiting
regularly in europe here he is in paris
in 1959
uh meeting with for the first time the
polish poet is a biggie of herbert
uh you can see the paintings scattered
around the room on the wall you can see
also the figure of the man how tall he
is the tower is over herbert and how
thin he is
i'll go through now a series of
paintings from this time
these subjects range from still lives
to interior scenes
you can imagine chapski coming out of
the door
of an apartment
onto the landing and looking down and
seeing this
he sketched it in his diary made several
versions of it and this is the final
painting
there's something about the headlessness
of the figure
that is curious and
became something of a trope in his work
again one wonders what prompts chavsky
to capture an image many of us might
otherwise have turned away from
he he claimed that
in proofst we come across an absolute
absence of bias
a willingness to know and understand as
many opposing states of the human soul
as possible a capacity for discovering
in the lowest of man such nobility as to
appear sublime
and in the seemingly purest of beings
the bassist instincts
chopsky shares this breath of curiosity
and fascination
a sequence of entries from the pages of
his diary
i bought a whole bunch of lilies
sometimes my own vision which being
ravished is intensified almost forcing
itself on me frees me unifies me
internally but for that to happen i need
access to deeper waters to counter the
flow of the ravishment these waters
i haven't got them
how often does this ravishment prove a
sterile ground
a cause of failure in a backing down
i wait not having the power in me to
make this leap forward to attack the
canvas
i want to paint the lilies in a very
modest picture
to apply a single go in a single go some
perfect juxtapositions
a brown
a velvety red the green of the leaves
the white of the flower
all of that is so beautiful
it stops me
chopski was always
a painter of doubt he doubted his own
abilities and he doubted what he was
able to produce
and whether or not it had value
he was very hard on himself
um and yet
his struggle this internal struggle
urged him on he had an enormous furnace
with him and burning with the desire to
remove the vision from within him and
put it onto the page
painting of his sister huja
he did portraits
he's he had people sit for him to keep
his discipline his hand
um he disliked formal commission
portraiture but he did it knowing that
it could bring positive results in terms
of commissioned work or sales
here are two formal portraits he did one
of herbert and the other of the
portuguese writer faratha murder
the fascination with the hands of the of
the writers is to me of great interest
this is a self-portrait in which chebsky
looks out at us circumspectly not quite
open-faced but present pensive about his
truncated eyeglasses he's unflustered
suggesting
my glasses are broken well yes okay it's
not a big deal
the picture he's looking out of is shown
at the easel on the right
everything appears rather matter of a
fact
but a light bulb is floating swimming
like a monet water lily in a lake of
luminous effects behind his head
is the subject of the painting the
painter's head or the bulb or the space
between them
there seems to be an acknowledgment of
shared territory
of fullness
and of emptiness
of being
and nothingness
existing together at once side by side
neither one state nor the other
prevailing
the atmosphere of the painting filled by
almost ecstatic brush strokes
put down with great effervescence
raises existential questions after the
fashion of beckett and
both of whom exerted powerful influences
on chapter at this time
he was able to catch psychological
states
often
pulling out of the
sitter
something that perhaps they didn't mean
to reveal
the painting on the right is one of the
first
examples that would become a genre for
chopski
of painting people looking at paintings
somehow he became so involved with the
work that he was at museums he would go
to galleries and not only the work
itself but the engagement of the people
with the work of art became significant
to him and became a subject of many
works
here the young man stands in front of an
abstract painting by nicolas destal
um
it is
an example of his
attempt to reconcile
non-representational abstraction with
his own work
putting an abstract painting into a
painting
of a figure so that you get both this is
a time
in paris where
abstraction non-representational
extraction became almost due a girl
and chaps he resisted it for for as for
many reasons for as long as he could he
tried to understand it but he was not
drawn to it
here are his sketches of people looking
at works that he did in museums and
galleries throughout paris
these books were filled with such
drawings
here in the centers a self-portrait of
him as an older man looking at a
painting
the awareness of himself
and others as they engaged
with works of art
this painting was done
after visiting a cool bay retrospective
at the grand palais
gets the opportunity to paint not only
what he sees but to paint the core bays
as well
and to reduce them to a certain kind of
essence of vision
the
technique of brushing so loosely in this
was
at a time when the same
free
immersion in
what might be called abstract
expressionist technique
was happening in new york
painters like philip gustin and grace
hartigan
embodied the use of that technique with
narrative paintings
that is very close to chopski's heart
he did not know their work
here's an example a detail of the way
that paint was put down
every brush stroke you must remember
requires a decision
vision chopski wrote is a shock
where willful choice between this or
that is
powerless a miracle of beauty which one
alone can see
unique
fleeting
imperceptible
or even held up to ridicule by others
very
characteristic choice of subject matter
the sense of presence and absence
the hope of transcendence and
the spark of those yellows and orange
dabs of paint
in 1980 chopsky turned 84.
he continued to work attacking the
canvas with more gusto and buoyant
energy
painting was a necessity for him and
essential as breathing and thinking
his eyesight began to diminish
erratically but his appetite for work
was unquenchable
as was true for monae and aga
encroaching blindness spurred him on to
new depths of seeing
he kept his tubes of paint and envelopes
with the name of the car scrawled in his
large hand to facilitate identification
as he worked
in his book late style the critic edward
syed wrote late style is what happens if
ark does not abdicate its rights in
favor of reality
the paintings chebsky made in his final
years reveal a harnessing of his vision
and a clarity of purpose few can match
in a time of physical decline he was
somehow gaining momentum
he persisted in his quixotic fashion
each canvas was a testimony and a
victory
when his beloved sister maria died he
wrote in his diary
before i die i would like to have a time
of painting in the high heat of work
he did have his time
and he worked it for all it was worth
he began a series of landscape paintings
in the early 80s as his eyesight was
beginning to wane
in this canvas called cloudburst
a trembling sky holds a gathering of
meteorological factors a highly dramatic
almost operatic scene
pure atmosphere has been triggered to
change the sky is vaporous
animated
insubstantial
a puffball of cloud hovers sparking a
kind of enchantment like a shakespearean
sprite
something magical emerges
chapski wrote to a friend
what's surprising is that i'm still
painting each time i start a canvas i
have the feeling that i'm fooling the
audience since i can see almost nothing
the touch of chopski's brush is fearless
whipping across the canvas like the wind
blowing over a field
diminished eyesight freed him from a
certain tyranny of form
it's as though he is letting his brush
do the seeing loading it up with color
he lets it play across the canvas
seeming to show him what it is he's
seeing as it moves along
several of the landscapes do version
pastoral cliche but his response to what
he sees is always free and unencumbered
the painting seemed to inhale vision
and exhale color
chomsky looked out on a moral universe
he was never indifferent to what he saw
trees and fields spoke their truth to
him revealing in a way
you could be in the world beyond the
storied failings of men
he spent his summers in the eel de
france walking every day sketchbook and
hands striding out among the open
farmland in rolling hills
the landscapes he painted in these years
present an allegorical marriage of the
bucolic and the impenetrable embodying
an almost biblical tension between
innocence and knowledge
the process
was referred to by the critic willian
epson
as putting the complex into the simple
these works are unself-conscious in a
new way poetic empathic pure
here's chapski in his room
with the self-portrait done
you'll see
on the far right side of the photograph
the lower shelf has
stacks of books leaning up one against
each other these are his diaries that he
always kept at hand
he slept in the bed he's sitting on now
with his head to the wall and every
morning he would reach up and grab at
random one of those
journal
volumes
he would read what he had read written
at some point in the past and he would
almost often annotate his response to
what he had read and then
find the latest
journal and begin his day afresh with
new musings
in 1981 martial law was declared in
poland
solidarity was banned and many of its
leaders were jailed a black and white
photograph of five prisoners walking on
a routine exercise break under a
makeshift netting of prison security
was smuggled out of poland and made the
rounds distributed to the world's press
chapski was moved to make a painting of
something he had not seen with his own
eyes
he had left krakow for paris in 1924 to
sever all relations with the overblown
style of historical painting but here he
made one of his own limiting his power
to the mixture of black and white
draining all color out of the image also
hinted at the western european idea of
life in a soviet satellite nation
a dismal prospect bleak dystopian
the figures appear weary and vulnerable
for forty years this painting hung in
the hallway leading to chopski's room
and his left feet
i like to think of this late canvas as a
companion piece station's great late
painting the flaying of marcius
full of emotional strength exuding
negative capability
the narrative elements are all there but
as mirandi's
as brazen miranda's quiet still lives
the picture is hardly about any of them
the surface is all rough and scumbled
almost whimsical the picture also gives
us a strong whiff of what the french
call podeshakh
a kind of progressive awareness of one's
mortality
we see the painter's thighs and knees
the tips of his shoes
he's engaged in viewing an exhibit of
paintings each reduced to a crude
rectangle with a yellow line around it
indicating a frame
the particular paintings hung on display
don't matter any more than the identity
of the painter
the painting is a study of chopsky's
sacred space his temple his place of
worship
his attempt to delineate the boundless
boundaries of the realm of art
a vast and anonymous expanse of the
imagination
greater than any specific work or
individual
in the 50s chapski had painted a
succeeded soprano singing tosca's arya
visi dhakti i lived for art
here
35 years later he painted himself as it
were singing the same anthem
he's both audience and performer
the gallery has no fourth wall
one of his latest paintings
done you can see is his eyesight is
really very minimal
there's a detail of it
in an essay called what abstract art
means to me willem de kooning conjecture
that art used to be about what one put
in a picture
then the time came when the question was
not of what one could paint
but what one could not
we went on to say
that
subject matter is the forever mute part
of the picture
you can talk about forever
here's chapski in his room and his
studio with his desk with his diary with
his paintings crammed one up against
another
fearless
going on for
full
full bore
never understood why he had not suffered
the same tragic end of his fellow
prisoners
two years before his death a year before
the fall of communism sorry a year after
the fall of communism he was informed by
a russian historian
in 1991
that a certain countess potopska and
count ferdinand de chestel
who had held sway with a german high
command during the war had interceded to
save his life
they convinced the officers that people
born in the areas annexed by nazi
germany fell under the jurisdiction of
the third reich
chapski who was born in prague was part
of that
apparently their influence was strong
enough to have the command agree
and they may have added his name to a
list of those to be spared
the nkvd received the list from the
german embassy on march 5th 1940 the
very day the public bureau signed the
order leading to the murder
of 22 000 polish officers
just a month
before the executions began
chapski didn't recognize either of the
two names
though it may well be true this report
is ultimately unverifiable so many
people wanted to know why chapski was
not among those who had been sacrificed
but in my opinion appearing on a list of
lies to be spared
and a polish officer
and then
titled aristocrat to boot
would have seemed more likely to have
made the nkvd want to kill him than
otherwise
these are chopsky's late journals
bought
at an art supply store in paris where
coincidentally i was also living and
bought my supplies
same time in
the 80s and
late 70s
a few days before his death he scribbled
in an awkward handwriting of a blind man
the words bonnard
matisse
goya and proust
and then in capital letters across many
pages the word cutting
here on the last pages of nearly 300
surviving volumes of his lifelong
journal for his final marks the
strokings of a pen on a sheet of paper
by a blind man in search of reassurance
that making a mark is a valuable
activity that it makes a difference
thank you
thank you eric um for for bringing to
our audience uh and and to our class
um a sense of the man and of his work
that otherwise would certainly
have escaped us
um thank you for for bringing to bear so
so humbly and and so so persuasively
um your your skills as a as a historian
of art and as an artist i feel like from
this
we have what i'd hoped we would have
which is an entirely different
angle of view um uh angle of view which
is itself about what it means to to see
which was chomsky's preoccupation his
lifelong preoccupation
i think i forgot when i introduced you
to remind the audience that the way we
ask questions is by
putting your name like by by is by using
i think it's a someone correct me if
necessary using the question and answer
function um down below
or by using the chat
um and uh and and writing down questions
so i didn't i didn't tell anyone this so
i don't i don't think i have any
questions yet
which um which which opens up for me the
possibility of abusing the privilege of
the chair and asking you the first one
um i'm gonna i'm gonna give the students
time to think about how they might ask
questions um related to the to the class
one thing which which you know is is uh
fairly clear in your presentation
although you don't say it outright
is that
chopski got better
he got he was he was better in middle
age
as a painter than he was as a young man
i believe it's fair to say and then one
could even say that as a very old man
he might have been better than he was
when he was in
middle age
and i was so i want to ask you if i'm
understanding you correctly i mean i
realized that better than worse than or
not words that artists like reach to
with with alacrity um but i forgive my
primitive way of putting it i want to
ask you if i'm understanding you
correctly and i also want to ask you
your views about
why
um of course in the in the context of
this class
we're we're thinking about we're
thinking about the the we're thinking
about soviet camps and incarceration in
general and experience
and chopski does have this you know
there's a striking fact that he and he
he can't really paint
for
um roughly a decade because of the
second world war and the things he felt
called upon to do and that he returns to
painting after 10 years
and that he's much more interesting i
think when he returns to it
that must have something to do with not
being able to paint
it must have something to do with the
camps and i guess the riddle would be or
the question i want to put you directly
is what what is your feeling about that
relationship like
i really i mean in some sense like
chopski as a creator
with the a few exceptions one of which
you showed the the 1981
martial law painting he's not someone
who is
you know except when except when he
except when he is directly rendering
something
in the camps he's not a painter who's
bringing the camps out into the world
right so there's not that kind of simple
relationship
but there must be some and i wonder if
in all of your thinking about this you
would share with us what you think that
relationship
might have been
um
there are a few questions in there
um
and i will try if i can to answer them
in the order they were asked about um
whether or not chopsticks got better
i feel that
chelsea was enormously privileged to be
able to live
97 years like you know he had the ark of
a painter
um that was quite
considerable
and he was a slow starter
when he was in paris he felt very
frustrated because the group of polish
painters around him all made enormous
strides
and he felt that he was
constantly
treading in place and not making
progress by the time he got back to
warsaw i think he had a
he had an increase in confidence in
himself i think some of this is about
uh one's relationship to
one's taking on a lifetime of painting
and whether or not one is qualified to
actually do that
and i think by the time he got back to
uh to
warsaw in the 30s he felt
emboldened and the
the companion experience of writing
about painting i think freed up a
certain part of the vision in him
because he could talk about it and
almost extract it from his mind that
freed his eyes to see something
so he was developing and he was finding
what his subject is the same way uh a
singer finds his voice i think
um and it was a very slow process which
was brutally interrupted just as it was
beginning to kind of
coalesce
when uh he left
in 1939
it was a decade a very sterile decade
that followed in terms of painting he
painted one painting in baghdad
that remains
a landscape of a street scene in baghdad
but primarily he was reduced to pen and
pencil and paper
and he made enormous use of that and i
think the lack of paint
enabled him
to
to
embody
what for him had already always been the
ideal that cezanne
determined was that you should
you should draw with color
draw directly with color rather than
draw with line and then paint in with
color and this is what all those 10
years of drawing
enabled him to see the confidence that
he could have that he could ultimately
when he got back to paint he could just
jump in and paint directly with the
color and that's in the 50s when his
work really begins to take off
i think
he
he was at that point not so much
concerned about
um
the quality of the work as it was the um
the subject of the work what was he
being called to paint
and this brings up another part of the
question that you that you have
was
how does a painter
determine what it is that his subject is
uh and it took a very long time for
chopski to
to find this
uh but it was ongoing all the time and
it was uh it was about the doubt that he
had internally that he would try one
subject after another but i think that
you're correct in saying that as he got
older the forces began to
come together in him
and he
somehow i think with the
beginning of the loss of
sight
when he turned to 80
the the the 15 years at the end of his
life were the most remarkable late
flowering of painting that
i i can imagine because not only was it
a maturing of a vision but it was really
the beginning
of confidence as a painter and the body
of work from 1980 to 1990
is is both massive and um and empowered
and as i said
um
uh about uh
edward syed saying that it is a
late style that has to do with
commitment to art rather than reality
and so he was able to give up the things
that had held him back before about
naturalism or about
about vision and just to embody the
painting to become a painter
yeah i mean he was he was a man who had
a lot of reality to give up
great deal and that's
also
part of your questions
what about the camps and and how did
that impact him i think he was
determined not to become a chronicler in
paint of those years
um and i think he was
uh he
unfortunately was in a position where he
had to become a chronicler
in words in literary form but he was
determined not to make that the subject
of his paintings
and that was part of a duality that
existed in him for a long time and it
took him a very long time to
to honor the ability to paint from
within himself somehow not being
selfishly um self-absorbed
which he could not afford to be
otherwise
yeah
and one one so we you know we we in our
class
we now have to have some nice questions
from students that i'm going to serve up
but in our class we're reading a bit of
inhuman land as you know
and having read the correspondence
between between him and and and heading
um you know it's it's very clear just
how much he suffered
like he didn't it was it was obviously
difficult to return to the period
but he he wasn't a writer he didn't see
himself as a writer i mean he was a
wonderful writer but he didn't see
himself as a writer it was hard for him
it was difficult for him he felt that
like as you suggest like he was this was
the wrong genre somehow he was on the
wrong he was in the wrong artistic orb
but this was not what he was
meant to be doing and you know they it
took the the the so the the product the
the inhuman land book
is a result of such struggle not just
struggle because of the substance but
also struggle because of a form
and that doesn't that doesn't come
through but like it's a it even exists
as a kind of
testimony to his like his determination
which also comes out in the ability to
just keep painting decade after decade
after decade after decade after after
decade i'm going to get the yeah go
ahead sorry i'm going to say that um he
writes very clearly like a painter yeah
very that's very good but he was
determined not to paint like a writer
yeah
yes that's beautiful
um
okay i'm going to give the floor now to
to our students
um
one of our students begins with actually
a classic question and one on which
my own perspective has changed partly
thanks to your work one of our students
asked
is chomsky remembered
as the historical figure
as the as the chronicler as the survivor
or is he remembered as as the artist
and i think part of the question is
should he be remembered as the
historical figure or should he be
remembered as the artist
it's a very complicated question a very
good question
it depends upon
who's doing the remembering
i think uh when i first went to poland
to begin researching this uh in 2013
[Music]
people in poland were were not really
uh aware of chopski as anything but a
historical figure
he was known as the survivor of katin he
was the one who carried the torch
if anything he was
admired for his
um
his
what seemed to be his national pride
uh which was not at all how he really
experienced his his life
um
my
um
in those years since the then
i think um what i've been able to find
is a greater
interest in his work as a painter
because
in
poland um
the standards of visual the visual arts
are very much controlled by the past
by the relation to the past there's an
enormously
freeing and powerful graphic arts um
part of polish art world but the
painting itself is is very much not
unlike what chopsky faced when he was in
the academy
in the in the 20s there is this
tradition and then there's the uh kind
of fashionable
and chopski
seems somehow now to speak to people
more directly because of his
individualism
which was considered a weakness earlier
on but it's now considered a strength so
i do think that chopsky is an
exceptional painter
i'm not making a case for him being a
great painter for me his life
his devotion to painting is really
what's key
i don't think you can put him on
a platform with there are many great
painters
there's a question here also of market
that char there's no real market value
for chopski so it's very hard to assess
him in terms of his greatness because in
the current mark in the current art
world greatness is predicated upon
auction prices
and chapski certainly doesn't
appear in the stratosphere
that way
whereas his work represents a certain
accomplishment that that i find
very inspiring and very meaningful
and i think
more and more young people are beginning
to recognize his work and gravitate
towards it
the next question i want to ask you from
a second student
um
i'm just gonna i'm gonna ask it in in in
her words because i think she's onto
something which is very important and it
complements what we were just talking
about
um
during his time in imprisonment chopski
experienced absence in a profound way
the men he saw one day were gone the
next
in what ways do you think that his
exposure to systemic loss or removal
inform his artistic style
specifically his fixation on the subject
on the subject
[Music]
well um chopsky's mother died when he
was six
and the sensation of loss is something
that he's done his entire life
um
i think that it informs
everything in an aesthetic sense with
him
that the idea of absence and presence
that dichotomy that kind of
um uh attempt
to show
the unseen
all of those
revolve around this tentative
relationship to to the world around us
i think he is profoundly
um
[Music]
immersed in a world of of loss
and his his
role his his life work is to
um not be
like
the caring not to be eclipsed
by that sense of loss not to be crippled
by it but to understand it and to use it
as a generative force
another student asks
much of chopski's art
seemed to center the act of looking
especially looking at art
do the body languages and facial
expressions of the figures in his
paintings
convey anything about his own attitude
about
looking critically or looking closely
well i think that it became a subject
for him is clear that yes it was very
important to him and it tells a great
deal about his involvement in that world
i think he
celebrated
the act of looking
the monograph that i put together of his
work i call an apprenticeship of looking
which was his term for what he
didn't consider that he had a career as
a painter he never valued himself that
highly he always thought of it what he
called as an apprenticeship he had of
looking
and
and
uh looking as um
edmund de goncourt said
is the longest of all the
apprenticeships in the art
and that's really very true
so this is what he is um he's
uh
again celebrating this idea of the
engagement of a viewer with a work of
art and also his opportunity to
to have that time
not just lost in the contemplation of a
work of art he wanted to keep it active
so he would step back from the painting
and see the room that he was in see the
gallery see the people who were involved
also
we um
we
some of the remaining questions are on
overlapping themes and some of them i
think we can best address in class
tomorrow and uh we have we have we have
made you work um not for not for 90
years but for at least for 90 minutes
which is
a good a good chunk of time i want to
thank you again eric for
first of all for all of the work you
have done to bring chopski to the world
you have begun a renewal which i hope
will continue and i hope this lecture in
this class will do something towards
bringing
his way of looking at things that
everyone should care about
closer to the center of conversations
um i want to thank you for entertaining
the questions of our class i want to
thank students for engaging with um with
this difficult material after their
previous difficult material and for
being with us and i want to thank all of
our guests for our numerous guests for
for joining us in this frankie lecture
so i'm timothy snyder we've been
listening to eric karpolis um and um i'm
i i'm
very pleased very happy that we could
bring all of this together in the
framework of the frankie lectures and
the framework of this class so thank you
again eric
thank you very much to everyone involved
and
i
uh
i respect and appreciate the work that's
being done by you and the class and the
idea of bringing this material to a
bigger world and a deeper understanding
of it so thank you very much